The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.MIT.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK,
let's get started.
A brief recap what we were
talking the last lecture--
we emphasized the
density of states,
which is a measure of how
many quantum states either
per frequency interval,
or per energy interval,
or per view vector,
magnitude interval,
or wavelength interval.
That's your choice.
And it's really a mathematics.
When I want to find the
sum of quantity f over all
the possible [INAUDIBLE].
Each setup of this combination
gives me one quantum state
if I include in this
P, polarization,
or spin as my addition or,
say, polarization-- generally,
I call this polarization, right?
So when I do this summation, I'm
summing all the quantum states.
And when this function
does not vary rapidly
over two adjacent
points of this k,
I can convert this
summation into integration.
So the density of
state is really
mathematical convenience,
but it's so widely used--
a very, very powerful tool.
So many times, we
talk about just people
will say, what's the DOS?
I mean, you calculate
the density of states
from different mature systems.
And later on, I hope we
will see some of this
when we do the, say, computer.
We'll look at what people
are plotting, right?
And then we used
simple relations.
So depends on this function.
Is this function
of function over e?
A function over k?
So you decide which one is
the most convenient for you,
whether you convert this
into e or k integration.
And there is a relation.
So to do that conversion
from k into E,
the relation between the
energy and the wave vector,
for electron, we use a
simple parabolic band.
And [? for ?] phonon/photon is
a linear dispersion that we use.
With that, we did
our math and say,
what's the corresponding
density of states?
So that's the emphasis.
We spent the most
amount of time there.
And also, we give example.
If you have quantization, right,
the separation of energy level.
Let's say in the z direction,
becomes very large.
I cannot convert this summation
into integration anymore.
I'll keep that sum, but I still
do-- in the xy right direction,
I still can convert
that into integration.
So we show the difference in the
density of states of 2D quantum
[? well ?] versus a bulk
paroblic [? biomaterial. ?]
And at the end of
last lecture, we
moved on to talking about
Fermi-Dirac distribution.
This is a now--
I have quantized energy
levels starting from--
if you recall in
the first chapter,
we introduced the
Boltzmann Factor,
the probability of a molecule
having certain energy.
And now we expanded that.
And we say this is
the Gibbs Factor.
This is the probability of a
quantum state being occupied
with energy, E, and with
the number of particle N.
So it's an open system.
All right, the
constant temperature--
mu is the chemical potential.
That's the energy that it
takes to take out or put
in a particle like that
energy into the system--
the average energy.
So chemical potential
is a driving force
for mass diffusion, temperature
is the driving force
for heat transfer, and
pressure is the driving force
for the volume change.
So those are the
thermodynamic quantities.
And we ask the question.
So when we apply
this, we need to find
the normalization
factor A because
of the probability of adding
up all possible possibilities
should give me 1.
So when I apply this to one
quantum state of electron,
a charge-- so it's
[? affirm, ?] [? yeah? ?] Right?
And this quantum state
is in thermal equilibrium
with the surrounding.
So in that quantum state, the
electrons then get in, get out.
It's an open system.
And there's a constant
temperature communication
with the surrounding electrons.
And if I apply the
probability summation,
I find the normalization factor.
And, eventually, I find the
average number of electrons
in that quantum state, E i, is
the Fermi-Dirac distribution--
E i mass mu over [? KBT ?]
exponential plus one.
That's what we
ended last lecture.
And I will continue.
So this is for Fermi, right?
Fermi-Dirac-- Fermi--
and in one quantum state,
I can have empty--
no particle there--
no electron there.
Or I can have
maximum one, right?
So that summation is easy to do.
And now let me extend
that to a boson.
So with that, I will
say, if it's a boson,
it's a Bose-Einstein
distribution.
And again, I consider a
quantum state with the energy--
say, this quantum
state that energy E i.
Right?
And boson-- quantums for boson--
one quantum state can have
zero to infinite possibilities,
all right?
It's [INAUDIBLE] the
Pauli exclusion principle.
So I can have the number of
particles could be 0, 1, 2--
so all at this end.
When I have 0--
the total energy
of the system's 0--
we'll have one that's a E i.
And then we'll have two
particles that's 2 E i.
That's a total energy
of the system, right,
of this specific energy
level, [INAUDIBLE],, OK?
And, again, then I go
to the Gibbs factor.
I say, the probability
of this quantum state
having a particle
between 0 to infinite
has to sum up equal to 1.
So I sum this up.
And that's the small end, right?
[? Factor N. ?] N
to 0 to infinite.
That's [? the ERRA, ?]
exponential mass E. So
that depends on if I
have an N particle.
I should have N times E i.
That's the energy.
And then I have N times
mu divided by KBT.
That equals 1.
Right?
So now you take all of this,
and you say E i minus mu.
That factor is a common factor.
And that is a geometric
[? surface, ?] right?
So if I do my summation for
this geometric [? surface, ?]
I get 1 minus exponential
minus E i minus mu.
KBT equals 1, OK?
Right, so this is the summation
of the geometric [? surface, ?]
and then I have A equals
1 minus exponential
minus E i minus the mu.
KBT.
So this give me the
normalization factor A.
And with this, I have the
probability of this state.
What's the probability of
this state having N particles?
I can write it down.
And, again, I can go to find
the average number of particles,
right?
So the average
number of particle--
I use f again.
This is for this energy level.
And either say temperature and
[? chemical ?] [? potential ?]
mu for the whole system.
That's the average
number of particles,
and that should equal
to the probability.
So it's N P E,
which we have here--
E and the N. And this
N equals 0 to infinite.
So I'm finding the average.
So this is when the
average [? award ?]
is N over the probability
I just derived,
was the normalization
factor, right?
So if you sum this up, you're
putting in the N equals 0
to infinite.
And this is the N. This
is my normalization.
It's 1 minus exponential minus
E i minus the mu [? KBT ?]
and times the exponential.
That's, again, the NEi
minus the N times the mu kBT
And that's the summation.
I should do sum
over all those N.
Well, there's a small mathematic
trick because N is here,
N is here, it's not a
simple geometric series.
And this mathematic trick is
if you take this function here,
and you do a derivative with
respect to this Ei minus mu,
you get the A in the front.
If you think of this as
my x, that's essentially
is the e minus N times the x.
And if you say,
that's my function,
I take the derivative
of that function,
that N will come to the front.
So with that, you can
do this summation.
I'm not going into the detail.
You can read the book.
And I'm going to give you the
final result of this exercise.
It will give you Ei, and T, mu
the average number of particle
for a boson in one quantum
state in thermal equilibrium
with the surrounding.
This is the Ei minus mu kBT.
Looks very similar.
Before I have [? there ?]
for Fermi-Dirac
I have plus 1, now
I have minus 1.
So Mathematica turns out
a very beautiful-- it's
just the difference between the
two particles is 1 plus, 1 is
minus.
And this is the Bose-Einstein
distribution, Bose-Einstein.
And compared to
Fermi-Dirac, if you say here
Ei minus mu divided
by kBT plus 1.
And because here is a plus
1, this numerator is 1,
you say for N here is
always between 0 and 1.
But that's not the case for
Bose-Einstein distribution
because this is a minus 1.
So if we look at the
typical how it looks like,
And for y let's say the
Fermi-Dirac distribution,
and because it's an
exponential function, kBT--
remember, kBT at
room temperature
is 26 millielectron-volts.
And if this one, Ei minus
mu, is much larger than kBT,
this was very large.
because remember I say, if
this is a [? leg ?] here,
that quickly can go to 0.
So you apply that,
here is your mu.
And for Fermi-Dirac is 1.
And pretty much all the way,
except the right-hand tool,
the E equals mu range where--
so this is the E of
the energy level.
And there's only around
the mu kBT range, 3 kBT.
And the rest is either 1 or 0.
So now if you'll think about
that when we discuss metal
before, we say, OK,
this is your Ef.
This is your Fermi level.
And Fermi level is actually very
close to the chemical potential
of mu.
I'll comment that later on.
But just think this is mu.
And you say only 3 kBT
near that level you have--
say below this, you
have some empty states.
Normally it's filled.
At zero temperature, it's
filled right to this level.
But along zero temperature
because of that Fermi-Dirac
distribution, there are
few empty states below
and a few mobile electron-volts.
So [? u ?] and metal allow
[? all ?] electrons are moving,
contributing to conduction.
Only near this Ef.
So that's one.
And now if you think about the
Bose-Einstein distribution,
what it look like is here is
your mu and here is your E.
And I cannot have
my E less than mu,
otherwise the average number
of particles is [? leg ?] here.
So when Ei approach
mu, this approach 1.
So that number could
be really large.
But Ei is much larger than
mu, this quickly drop.
So this is my
Bose-Einstein distribution.
So you probably already heard
Bose-Einstein condensate.
A few years ago, the
Physics Department Ketterle
got a Nobel Prize for the work
in Bose-Einstein condensate.
What is it?
So if you look at this, when
you go to very low temperature,
this kBT is very small and
10 to the minus 5 Kelvin.
And then when this one gets
to, say, really close to mu,
it turns out this number is
getting really very large.
This goes very large.
So what they means is
this one energy state
that all the particles fall into
that energy state, one quantum
state.
So they condense into
that quantum state.
That's the simple
Bose-Einstein condensate.
And the trick is you
got to get that, say,
temperature really, really low.
So it turns out that that
does say there was a--
Einstein, this was predicted
a very, very long time ago,
but nobody were able to
drive to that temperature.
And the Physics Department
and Ketterle and a few others
have been trying to drive
this to a very low temperature
for many years by using various
refrigeration technique,
getting to a low temperature.
And in fact, they were beaten.
They didn't win.
And it was their student.
And went to NIST right now at
the Colorado, Boulder NIST.
NIST thought about a way to do
the Bose-Einstein condensate
much easier.
And the way they did it is
to use the laser cooling.
Now while you can
cool with laser,
you typically think
about the heating stuff.
And so when you have a laser
beam come in, and what it does
is using this Doppler effect,
but really pretty much
like using the momentum
of the photons.
And let's say when
the molecule move
in one direction, the photon
just hit it so it doesn't move,
so pretty much make
them stationary.
And when they make
it stationary,
their temperature is low.
So with that, they did
the cooling on, let's say,
optical table and got the
Bose-Einstein condensate
so that the Nobel price was
given three people and two
from NIST and one from physics.
Ketterle, they did
a lot of, let's say,
beautiful experiment
using that technique.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
that the molecules obey
the Bose-Einstein distribution?
GANG CHEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But don't they
have the exclusion principle?
GANG CHEN: No.
AUDIENCE: Is it a
[? macroscopic ?] description?
GANG CHEN: Well, they
have a net charge zero.
They have positive
and negative charge.
Molecules are [? based ?]
[? on ?] Bose-Einstein.
And yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you clarify
what the difference is
between these two graphs and
what they're each spotting?
[INAUDIBLE]
GANG CHEN: Well, let's
say here is Fermi-Dirac,
and here is distribution
for Bose-Einstein--
Bose-Einstein.
That's the f.
And so you should go out and
be the advisors, that's why.
So that's the one part.
And in fact, this
laser cooling, this
is where Steven Chu got the
Nobel Prize, the current DOE
Secretary.
He did this laser
cooling experiment,
and he got the Nobel
Prize on laser cooling.
So before they gave the
Bose-Einstein condensate
the Nobel Prize, they have to
give the cooling Nobel Prize.
If you haven't
escaped, you goofed.
And this last year was graphene.
And between graphene and--
there is another one.
And this is you see, carbon-60.
That was Richard Smalley.
And carbon-60 is the other
form of carbon atoms arranged
in like a soccer ball.
And then in '91, '93--
well, '91, it was you
say [? jimma, ?] so
he grew this nanotube.
He didn't really grew.
He just found in the dust.
And this was, let's
say, carbon dust,
and he looked at it at [? TM, ?]
and they found those tubes.
So that that's pretty much
like another form of carbon.
And so Japan--
I'm going to say a
lot of people say
they probably get Nobel Prize.
I actually wish to
get a Nobel Prize.
But they skipped and
went to the graphene.
You got the scotch
tape, that's easier.
Anyway.
So first point,
the distribution.
The second is, what's
the chemical potential
for photon and phonon?
And then typically we say for
photon and same for phonon,
the user argument is a
chemical potential of 0.
Mu is 0.
And the reason to
argue that mu is 0
is that, let's say, it's
not a conserved particle.
Photon, phonon,
it can disappear.
Light get absorbed, it becomes,
heat, get the whole phonon,
they disappear.
Another electron is
always somewhere.
It went somewhere, but
it doesn't get destroyed.
So that's the argument.
So [? their ?] N you
should not have a--
because this is a
tangent, that mu is 0.
That's the argument for--
typically it's correct
for thermoradiation
or for thermal
phonons, mu equals 0.
But over the years I've
been actually asking this,
struggling with
this because if you
look at the electronic device--
say after electronic
device, the lasers and LEDs.
And what happens to the
light emission in that case
is the light is emitted.
So you have conduction
bad, you have balance bad.
And an electron goes
from here to here
where you meet the photon.
That's the emission.
Light and electron from
high energy to lower energy,
they could convert that into
photon emission process.
And in laser and LED, it
turns out the electrons
and the host are not in
equilibrium with each other.
And the electron has
a chemical potential,
and host has a
chemical potential.
And this was also called the
quasi Fermi level, so Ef,
let's say, n, this is Efp.
Each of them have their own--
if you take them as a system,
they have a chemical potential.
And in this case, the
photon emitted actually
has a chemical potential of mu.
And mu equals the
difference of Efn and Efp.
So your distribution
function is here.
You should write this Ei is
h nu at a certain energy,
and the minus mu.
So in fact, photons can indeed
have a chemical potential.
And that's when they interact
with other long equilibrium
systems, like an electron.
I'm not seeing people discuss
phonon or nobody has really
probably encountered
that situation where
phonons are emitted by--
let's say if I can imagine
if only phonons [? by ?]
emitted the same process, by
allowing equilibrium electron
holes, I should write
the same simple formula.
But nobody has created
a system like that.
And maybe some people
talk about phonon lasers.
That might be you have
to write that way.
So those are the
statistical distribution
for electrons and phonons,
and now I'm eager to use it.
So what we have derived,
if you think about this,
is I solved [? Schrodinger ?]
equation, and now
the energy level, and
now the quantum state.
And using density of states,
I know near each energy level
how many states it has.
And now I know using the
Bose-Einstein, Fermi-Dirac
distribution, I know
on each quantum state
how many particles.
This is either
thermal or equilibrium
I'm not talking about
long equilibrium case yet.
So I can count the energy
stored in the system--
thermal energy
stored in the system.
So let's do that.
So let's look at the examples.
My first example is photon
blackbody radiation.
Let me say I have a cavity.
Inside the cavity of
photons in equilibrium
with the surrounding temperature
T. This is actually--
if you go to read the Planck's
book, it's very interesting.
1905 he discussed those.
And photons itself, how
could they reach equilibrium?
So you have to actually
say maybe there
are some gas, very diluted
atoms there and they help you
[? have ?] in the process.
But let's say I have a cavity
with the photons in equilibrium
at the temperature
T. Then what's
the total energy of the
photons in the cavity?
So the total energy is u in
this cavity is, of course,
the polarization of
light and kx, ky, kz.
kx, that's the mode.
ky, kz, that's what we
are doing [? when ?] we
say we need to convert this
submission into integration.
Each [? cell ?] [? of ?] kx,
ky, kz gives me one state.
And each state, say
one state, this state
could have a frequency omega.
The energy of that one photon
is h omega, one photon.
But say on each state
how many photons
have is by the
Bose-Einstein distribution.
So this is the Bose-Einstein
at a temperature T. So this is
either frequency or energy.
Energy is h nu--
or omega.
Let me use omega--
omega, and temperature T. And
I said is a thermal radiation
blackbody.
Mu equals 0, so
I don't carry mu.
So that's what I need to do.
And now I assume you
know how to do it.
Last lecture we spent time
converting the submission
into integration, so I'm going
to just write the integration.
I'm going to use the
density of states.
If at the beginning we say,
it's converting this submission
in the density of states.
I'm going to do the density of
states in the omega frequency.
So I'm going to write this is--
it turns out that the volume
is here because, let's say, it
depends on if I use the density
of states per unit volume, then
h bar omega f Bose-Einstein
distribution times
D omega and d omega.
So I'm converting the
submission into integration.
And my photon frequency
could be 0 to infinite.
So this is my math there.
What do we get?
Let's do a few more steps.
You can go to check.
So I could write that u divided
by v is the per unit volume.
What's the energy density
in terms of function
for frequency omega?
And I have, if you
check, 0 to infinite
h bar omega exponential
h bar omega kBT minus 1.
And say density of
states for photon,
you can look at
your notes, is omega
squared the speed of light
cubic pi squared and d omega.
I should not put an omega here.
This is an integration already.
And what's inside is
the function of omega.
This is the energy density per
unit volume of those photons.
And what you see
inside essentially
is Planck's blackbody radiation.
It's very easy.
What Plank is really
saying, you have
to have that quantization to
get this kind of distribution.
And the rest is just so they--
I say each mode how many photons
times the energy of one photon
times how many
modes I have here.
And so that's the--
see here what's
inside is u omega.
And normally we do not
write the Planck's law
in terms of the energy density.
We write the emissive power or
rather in terms of intensity.
And also here I have
photons per unit volume.
I know the energy
of this photon.
And those photons are
moving to all directions,
blackbody radiation,
at the speed of light.
So what the intensity
is defined, the per unit
direction, unit solid angle,
what's the flux of energy?
So intensity of light is a
per unit solid angle in space.
This is basically per unit
direction [? there. ?] How much
[? energy? ?] And the total
space solid angle is how much?
4 pi.
That's the whole, right?
In a plane, there's 2 pi.
In a sphere, it's 4 pi.
So I have 4 pi, that's a per
unit solid angle, times u
omega.
So that's the total energy.
And this energy is moving
at the speed of light.
That gives me the intensity.
And if you go to a
book, you normally
don't write into omega.
In heat transfer, we don't
like to use of omega.
We like to use
lambda, wavelengths.
So the relation
is here going back
to whether you choose
omega or you choose lambda.
You need to do a conversion.
So if you do lambda, I
lambda is really omega--
you can convert your
omega into lambda
because we say omega equals
this c times k equals
c 2 pi over lambda.
So let's say you
replace the omega.
But you need to be careful
because your integration is
over d lambda.
So now you have to
do d omega d lambda.
And this gives me--
now I write you
the typical form,
is 4 pi h bar c squared and
lambda fifth power exponential
h bar c and kB lambda T minus 1.
So this is the form--
if you had, let's
say, taken a course
that talk about blackbody
radiation, like heat transfer,
you've probably seen this.
And typically you will see
this is one constant, that's
another constant.
So you write in two
given constants.
But those are all in terms
of the fundamental physical
constants.
And you can see here this
lambda T. And in fact,
if you normalize this by also
temperature to the fifth power,
this also will be a
function of lambda T.
So this blackbody
radiation, Planck's law,
if you apply that as
a function of lambda,
[? all ?] [? I'll ?]
say is here,
and there's the peak here,
and lambda T is about 3,000
micron-Kelvin.
We mentioned this before.
See the [? science ?]
temperature is about 6,000.
That's why our eyes are
sensitive because the 3,000
divided by 6,000, 0.5 micron.
The solar system, we got
used to the evolution
towards during the day
looking at the sun.
You can imagine if
there is intelligence
in the outer solar
systems that will
be a different wavelengths.
It depends on the
temperature of the sun there.
So that's the
blackbody radiation.
And if you go to look at
the integration, this is a--
so you see here is
you integrated omega,
omega, omega squared.
And this is a 0 to infinite.
So if you do your
integration, you
can say, OK, because this
is [? 1 ?] omega over T,
I can get this exponential
into one variable x.
So if I do h bar
omega kBT into my x,
then you say omega
is proportional to x.
So omega will be
proportional to x times T.
So here if I do that, this
omega will give me one T,
this omega will
give me 2T squared,
give me another T.
So what I have if I
integrate it, I will gather u
equals T fourth power,
whatever constant.
This is once you convert
it into intensity
or into emissive power, which
is the pi times intensity,
you got the sigma
T fourth power.
So you see those were
the [? Wilhelm ?]
Wien got Nobel Prize
displacement law You
go to check the history.
And Planck got the Nobel Prize.
And, I don't know if Stefan--
this is Stefan-Boltzmann law.
Those were all empirical,
and they came out naturally
out of this.
So now that's a photon, right?
Let's look at the next phonon.
It's very similar.
So phonons.
And for phonons, if you recall,
the typical dispersion of
phonons, I have, of course, this
[? is a ?] dispersion, optical,
let's say, acoustic phonons.
But I'm going to
use the Debye model.
So here is the frequency, here
is the wave vector pi over a,
and this is my Debye
model, linear, very crude.
And this is omega D.
A real crystal is isotropic.
In each direction, there is
a different lattice constant.
The Debye is actually collapsing
all three polarization
transfers longitudinal into
one and also make this crystal
equivalently isotropic.
So in fact, I have to say this
is my Debye equivalent lattice
constant.
And I need to first
find out, what's
the equivalent lattice constant?
And if I have, say, N
atoms in the crystal,
and in terms of each
atom we can do--
if you say, OK, in terms of
the mode or in terms of the--
let's say you have
three directions, so you
have each direction--
so you essentially
have 3N modes.
So I have 3N modes in
total, and two transfers,
one [? non-Schrodinger. ?]
And now I need to
make the equivalent,
say, [? unicell ?] to generate
the same number of modes.
So what does that mean?
That means if I have 3N,
that's the number mode,
and I sum up the
polarization is P3,
I have kx, ky, kz, that times 1.
Each set of kx, ky, kz gives
me one mode, and that plus P,
polarization 3.
So if you do that--
and again, you write it in
terms of density of states,
so it's the volume here.
And density of states for
phonon, you go to check
is-- the only
difference from photon
is it has three polarization.
Here I have two polarization.
So I look at that, omega
squared c cubic pi square.
So it's 3/2 and the v cubic.
And this is the Debye
velocity, and the pi square,
and the d omega.
So this is a my
density of states
when I convert this
submission into integration.
And I do a d omega.
So omega now, unlike light,
which I integrate from 0
to infinite, now I only
go from 0 to omega D.
So it's 0 to omega D.
And 3N divided by v.
[? That's ?] [? they ?]
[? say ?] you know the volume.
And you also know the relation
between omega D. omega D
is the Debye velocity,
that's the slope here,
times the wave vector,
so equals pi aD.
So omega D is related
to the Debye velocity
and the equivalent lattice
constant, Debye lattice
constant.
So by combining
these two relations,
I can find what's the
corresponding lattice constant.
Essentially I solve this, I
get pi aD equals 6N divide
by v pi squared 1/3.
And you can also say
this Debye frequency is
6N v pi squared 1/3 times vD.
So given the number for
atoms per unit volume,
I give you equivalent lattice
constant for the Debye model.
And the rest is very
similar to photon.
Right now I'm going to find
out what the total energy is
h omega times this Bose-Einstein
distribution replaced
with the phonon density of
states integrated from 0
to omega D. So it's identical.
I find out now it's
something I can measure.
For phonon, I can
measure the energy.
So this is u(T), temperature.
Let's say this small u is
capital U per unit volume
and is 0 to omega D and h bar
omega exponential h bar omega
kBT minus 1.
Density of states, we
have 3 omega squared
and 2 pi squared d omega--
v cubic, right?
v cubic.
And it's the Debye
velocity cubic.
So that's what I have here,
the density of states.
How many states?
Each state that have phonon
frequency omega energy, h bar
omega, how many
phonon in that state?
Everything looks very similar.
Difference is omega d
rather than infinite,
vD rather than speed of light.
Now this is the energy
per unit volume for solid.
Now you can think about this
crystal that you can measure.
And when you measure, what
do you measure typically?
For solid.
You don't-- huh?
AUDIENCE: Temperature.
GANG CHEN: Temperature
is thermodynamic, right?
Out here, all these
are thermodynamic.
But you measure specific heat.
You add energy, you see
how much temperature rise.
So the specific heat, c, per
unit volume is, let's say,
du/dT.
So take a derivative
of this, and now let's
say you can take a du/dT,
everything is inside,
only here is the temperature.
There could be a little
bit of thermal expansion.
a, lattice constant, could be a
small function of temperature.
But the main change come from
the Bose-Einstein factor here.
So if I take this,
everything as a constant,
I can do analytically
my differentiation
and then do the integration.
Right?
Now let me come back to here.
The photon, if I do integration,
is a T fourth power, right?
What's the specific heat?
Does that mean specific
heat is 2T cubic power?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GANG CHEN: A low temperature.
A low temperature is 2T cubic.
That's because when you go
to very low temperature,
this omega D is effectively
very large because here this
is small so that it's like
your upper limit is infinite.
So at very low temperature,
your specific heat
is actually T cubic.
It's just like photons.
It's a phonon gas.
So if you plot the specific
heat of most materials, what
you find is a trend like this.
It eventually goes
to a constant.
And the low temperature, this
region, is T cubic power.
At high temperature,
it's constant.
What is that constant?
At a high temperature--
that's because when
we go high temperature, it's no
longer integration to infinite.
So it turns out if
you do an integration,
it goes to that constant value.
And this fundamentally is
the equipartition theorem.
Remember, we mentioned
equipartition.
At high temperature, each mode
contribute average [? beacon ?]
1/2 kBT, each freedom.
If it's the motion, it's
a quadratic, So 1/2 kBT.
So if I think about the
atom in the crystal,
I have atom in the crystal,
let's say it moves.
It's kx, ky-- let's say
you have 1/2 mvx, mvy, mvz,
and mvz square, each one.
So you have three.
And I have kx squared,
1/2 kx squared,
that's another energy mode,
kx squared, ky squared,
kz squared.
So that's six.
So at high temperature,
the energy of each atom
is six times the 1/2 kBT.
That's the energy.
Now you take a derivative
to temperature, because
of that specific heat,
so you got the 3kB.
So this one should be a 3kB
and, say, number of atoms
divided by per unit volume.
So this Dulong-Petit law--
Dulong-Petit law.
It's a equipartition theory
at a high temperature.
Low temperature you go to cubic.
It's right?
So what Einstein-- so
Einstein actually first
to propose a model to explain
specific heat of crystals.
He didn't use the Debye model.
He used this omega E model.
The omega E, if you do that,
you don't do integration,
you gather the density of
state modes is all just--
I have 6N modes,
just the h omega
times this times 6N modes.
So if you do Einstein
model, you integrate--
you don't integrate because of
this frequency, omega Einstein
already.
The problem is when you
go to low temperature,
this is exponential function.
And experimentally it was
measured as a cubic function,
cubic rather than exponential.
So this is where, let's say,
it was proven the Einstein
model was not correct.
Specific heat, any questions?
A few more comment.
The real crystals are neither,
say, a simple Debye or Einstein
if you look at dispersion.
So what typically people
do is they will measure--
they will measure specific heat,
and they use Debye temperature.
So it's kBTD equals
h bar omega D.
So you can say if you
measured specific heat,
you fit the omega
D, you divide by kB,
you get the equivalent
Debye temperature.
So TD gives you
And Debye temperature-- so if
you look at the real crystal
dispersion we said before--
and you can see at a
very low temperature,
acoustic phonons are most
important, lower energy.
Once you go to a
higher temperature,
they start to kick in.
Because of the higher
energy, the exponent
become also important.
So, in fact, seldom you can
use just one temperature
to feed that whole curve.
So this Debye
temperature sometimes
is a function of temperature.
It's just a fitting.
So the point I want
to make is you can
fit an integral very easily.
An integral is forgiving.
You made some errors,
integration is smudged it out.
If you take a derivative,
it's much more
difficult to get it to
agree with the experiment.
So it turns out many
times when we do model
for transport properties--
and later on you'll see
most transport properties
are integrals.
So you say, OK, this is the
form, I feed the experiment,
you often get a beautiful fit.
It doesn't mean you
get things right.
So that's what I want
to say there, comment.
So this is the day
we talk about photon,
we talk about the phonon.
And what about the electrons?
And electron, you can again
use the same strategy.
Say here is the energy of the--
I go to solve the
dispersion of the electrons.
And I say the energy of
electrons of the system
due to electron a
certain temperature,
electrons have to carry
chemical potential.
So T and mu is summation
for polarization.
That's a spin up, spin
down, and kx, ky, kz.
And the electron is
energy of that mode.
And normally I don't like to use
the h bar omega for electron.
I just [? say ?] this energy.
And then the Fermi-Dirac, this
is the energy of that level.
I say the energy and how
many electrons at that level,
say at that quantum state.
So this is the energy
of the electron system.
And, of course, you can
take a derivative of this.
Again, it's specific heat.
But you have one trouble.
You have an extra mu there.
I said before mu is close to Ef.
But in theory you still have
to actually determine that mu.
How you determine that
mu is for electron,
you have fixed
number of electrons.
So the total number of electron
you know in the system.
And that total
number of electrons,
again, I do this summation, is--
so each state, the average
number of electrons
is Fermi-Dirac.
So I have E minus mu kBT plus 1.
So I have one equation
here, another equation here.
And using this
equation I can say
if you gave me N I can find mu.
I substitute mu back
into here, which
is a function of temperature,
mu is a function of temperature,
I substitute it back
here, I take a derivative,
now I have one temperature
here, another temperature there.
So it's more complicated.
But it's doable.
Mathematically, [? I'm ?]
[? closed ?] problem.
So I'm not going to do it.
I just gave it.
So you go to do the
electron specific heat,
you will find out
electron specific heat
approximately metal is
1/2 pi squared N over v.
N is number of electrons.
And kBT over TF.
TF is the Fermi temperature.
So electron temperature,
specific heat,
is a temperature--
is a function linearly
proportional to temperature.
And so what's the TF is kBTF
equals Ef, Fermi energy.
So that's the difference.
Sometimes the people
do model, and they all
use a constant specific
heat for electron.
And you can tell them it's
wrong because the TF is
very high because it's
a few electron-volts.
If it's 300 Kelvin, it's
only 26 millielectron-volts.
Ef is typically-- Fermi level
is a few electron-volts,
a few electrons divided by
26 millielectron times 300.
That's the equivalent
Fermi temperature,
a very high temperature.
So most of the time
you're in this region.
When the temperature
is lower than TF,
you have the linear
distribution.
Any questions?
I talked about the
specific heat and the other
[? says ?] this is the
Stefan-Boltzmann law.
And one other comment
is now you can
say if you want to take a
derivative of that energy
of photons, you get
specific heat of photon,
which is normally do not talk
about specific heat of photon.
It's very low.
It's hard to measure.
Any questions here?
OK, if not, let's say we--
this is almost like I can just
stop here and use this result
and move on to next.
That's pretty much
you take a semester
course on statistical physics,
you learn only this stuff.
[LAUGHING] One lecture.
We have what?
We had the three or four
lecture on solid state
and two lecture on quantum, one
lecture on statistical physics
you learn everything.
But I don't want to let you go
because you go talk to others,
you may still appear ignorant.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think metal
and semiconductors
should have very
different electronics
specific heat because
of the band gap.
So--
GANG CHEN: Very good.
Yeah, good question, yes.
So when you go to
a semiconductor,
again, you have to use this
to find the Fermi level
and then go to that, you
can still do the same.
Actually, I do not know whether
semiconductor it's linear.
It's a good question to check.
Yeah, I do not know.
I haven't really
checked that myself.
So, of course, what
you learn is the case
Fermi-Dirac,
Bose-Einstein, right?
And together if you
see the second lecture,
we learn Maxwell distribution.
That's the classical
Boltzmann limit.
But see, there are some really
very commonly used terminology
in statistical thermodynamics.
So that I'm not
going to test you.
And we normally do-- sorry,
we normally do not use it.
So I will not--
I will not--
I need to turn this off.
Forgot it this time.
So what I'm going
to use to really
do a little extra is to
give you a little bit
introduction to the basic
language [? barrier, ?]
what the people talk
in statistical physics.
It's actually a very
beautiful [? treatment. ?]
So what we hear is the
fundamentals, I would say,
in statistic physics.
So what are the
fundamental concept?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sir, I have a
quick question back to there.
GANG CHEN: Uh-huh,
AUDIENCE: Rather than it being
the energy and focus of omega--
GANG CHEN: Right.
AUDIENCE: --and
specifically omega,
isn't it like the
expected value because--
GANG CHEN: Well, this is the--
let's say I have--
you saw quantum mechanics, so
you know the energy level--
let's suppose you have,
say, a photon emitted
at a certain
frequency, so that's
the energy of this same mode,
the electromagnetic mode.
So if I have standing wave here,
that's an electromagnetic mode.
And so one photon
with that mode that
has a corresponding frequency,
the energy is h omega.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But that whole quantity--
GANG CHEN: This?
AUDIENCE: --because you were
talking about a probability
and a density.
GANG CHEN: Right.
So what do you say
is the probable--
what are you asking, why this is
not a probable energy density?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GANG CHEN: It is a
probable energy density.
It's just that normally the
deviation is really, really,
really small.
So you measure it,
there-- you can always
measure some fluctuations.
But say that deviation
from that fluctuation
will be very, very small.
In fact, that's a very
interesting topic itself.
OK?
Yeah.
So the concept I want to say
is that when we do statistics,
we want to do time average.
So normally I cannot
measure or verify--
say let's suppose I have
the internal energy.
It's fluctuating over time.
And if I do any measurement,
I have to over a certain time.
I will integrate that, say,
quantity over this time
and get the time average.
That's what I can measure.
Nobody can say I'm
going to measure really
instantaneous energy there.
So that's the time
average of any quantity.
And this is a system I have, and
I measure the average quantity.
But in statistics, it's
hard to do time treatment.
The time treatment, you need to
read the chapter 10 of my book.
I don't know whether
I can get there.
That's another
direction when you
do statistics is do time
treatment, time averaging.
But say what people
normally do is
rather than doing
time treatment,
they'll look at the ensemble.
It's like more doing
space treatment.
What's an ensemble?
So ensemble, it's a
collection for quantum state.
Let's say this system
is a microscopic system.
If I suppose I can
solve quantum mechanics,
I can find the all quantum
state of this system.
The total number,
total quantum state--
quantum states-- let's
say total number is omega.
So when I construct an ensemble,
I look at each quantum state
is one system, each
of this as one system.
You can see that's
a huge, huge number.
And then in each of
this quantum state
this quantity has
a certain value.
I may have a quantum
state where, say, all--
there is no particle there.
In that case, the energy
of that whole system
in that quantum state is zero.
So each of this I have,
let's say, this quantity.
And then what I do is
the ensemble average
is, what's the probability--
so now I'm saying the
probability of observing
this quantum state is p.
So what I do is xiPi.
And the i's sum up all quantum
states in this ensemble.
So here I have the time average.
Here is the ensemble average.
So in statistical
treatment is mostly
treating this ensemble average.
And it turns out there
are different probability
distribution.
It depends on whether
this ensemble--
the system I'm trading is
at a constant temperature
or constant energy, whether
it's a closed system
or whether it's an open system.
So those are
different ensembles.
And where we're going at the
beginning of next lecture,
I'm going to discuss
this in some ways,
we start with the
basic ensemble,
microcanonical, it's a closed
system, and constant energy,
and go into a system that's
constant temperature.
When the system is
constant temperature,
it means it can actually change
it with the surrounding energy
to maintain the constant
temperature, but closed.
And then let's say if I
have particle exchange
with the surrounding,
mass transfer,
then I have grand canonical.
So you go from gives
this probability
to Boltzmann factor--
no, Boltzmann principle
to Boltzmann factor
to Gibbs factor with this
different ensemble treatment.
So that's where I just wanted
to say where we're going.
But I wanted to use
some time to look at the
do a little bit surfing, right?
So what I'm going to--
first, let's look at
the density of states.
So let's look at the
phonon density of states.
So even though everything
looked very, say--
when we give an
analytical expression,
if you really look
at the phonon,
phonon is omega squared, right?
We just used it.
And you see here it's not
exactly omega squared.
See this region, very
low frequency region,
that's linear.
That's where it look
more omega squared.
Once you go to optical
phonon, transfers,
[INAUDIBLE] optical phonon,
you see it's know longer that.
That say omega squared
is no longer the picture.
And when we calculate
energy, remember
we're integrating over a density
of states for the Einstein
distribution.
We are using our parabola,
parabolic distribution,
to represent this function.
How good it is?
You should now feel very
uncomfortable, right?
But people use it.
And a different mature system.
So what does that say
here is, again, this
is where maybe the Debye
approximation is fine.
And those are the typical when
you have different direction,
different [? actually ?]
transfer is optical phonon--
let's say acoustic phonon,
and you get to here,
they're optical phonons.
So people don't allow--
this is a-- you can do
mostly by competition.
You can also do some--
say, use a neutron to measure
it, electron density of states.
So here, this is like
quantum well we discussed,
is the staircases.
And this is probably
quantum wires.
They're spikes.
Dots is the more isolated lines.
And that's the typical
parabolic approximation we use.
And you have to look at the--
let's see, where is your--
where your Ef, so
electronic band structure,
let's say for what,
silicon again?
So first you have to
go to look at the where
is the Fermi level?
[? Filled ?] to the top.
And then say for transport,
what you really care?
If you look at the
electron transport,
you should look at what's the
density of state near the Fermi
level?
Because that's
where kBT was set.
If it's too far away, this
region will most likely--
it's not involved in transfer.
They are field electron.
Now electron can move there.
So what's interesting
is really what
the density of states
near the Fermi level.
And I'll give you another,
[? well, ?] resonant levels.
Let's look at this.
What is this?
So sometimes what people say,
if you dope a semiconductor,
you put, let's say, E minus Ef.
So 0 is the Ef here.
And you put the atom in--
say you put in some
impurity atoms,
and they could create
some sharp features
in the density of states.
And those sharp
features could be
very interesting for
transport because if you
have sharp features,
it means there
could be a lot of charge there.
And the velocity of this
carrier is the slope.
If I have-- so it's the slope--
[? group ?] velocity is
the slope of this line.
It's the dispersion lines.
So typically, and for example
when we do thermoelectrics,
we like those who have those
sharp features because I like
to have a lot of charge
so that I can have
high electric conductivity.
It's the density
of states times--
the [? number ?] density
is, say, F times D.
And if the D is large,
I could potentially
get a very high
[? number ?] density.
And then, of course,
I have to care
about the other properties.
So I have to align
my Fermi level.
And how I align my Fermi level
is by controlling the doping.
So I can change the doping
and change that formula.
So I thought I'll stop here.
Any questions?
I was looking at the papers.
And I could go to--
if you go to Physics
Today website,
for example, you'll see
people doing cold atoms.
What the cold atoms
mean, you know
it will be relatable to
Bose-Einstein composition.
A lot of flux on cold atoms.
OK?